foreign
[Music]
of me that thinks icelanders might not
be the brightest of people
I mean look at this place
it's mostly made up of barren volcanic
rock that belges
pushing the foul smell of sulfur
throughout the countryside
animals and plants have avoided this
cold hard land
and so too should have humans
but as we all know
humans are a stupid yet wonderfully
determined species we often live where
we're not welcome
over the last hundred years icelanders
found a way not just to survive but to
thrive they became some of the world's
best fishermen
they invented their ways out of problems
and they even found a way to turn their
love of sagas
[Applause]
Elvish folklore
and storytelling into massive businesses
this is a place where the land and a
never-ending battle with nature
has had a profound influence on the
country's technology
[Music]
icelanders
they go about their daily lives secure
in the knowledge that 100 of their
country's energy is renewable
[Music]
partly thanks to this stuff
[Music]
Iceland has turned its volcanoes into
allies
geothermal Pockets to heat homes and
water
using hydroelectric dams for electricity
this energy self-sufficiency is key to
Iceland's Prosperity now Iceland hopes
to export its green energy smarts
some clever Engineers have created a
funky rugged wind turbine
it'll be used in Iceland to power
isolated summer homes and remote
industrial equipment
and to bring green energy to rural areas
overseas we're on a side of the highway
about 20 miles outside of Reykjavik you
can see this little guy spinning around
all day powering telecommunications
equipment
back in downtown Reykjavik there's
smaller versions of this sitting on top
of a bus stop they're powering a Wi-Fi
base station an advertising board and a
smartphone recharging station
[Music]
in an industrial suburb on the edge of
Reykjavik a company called Iceland has
set up shop in an abandoned Coal Power
Plant to build these turbines by hand
it's run by Thor the company's business
Chief and sea Thor a former nuclear
engineer
this type of turbine is called the seven
years vertical axis wind turbine
vertical access wind turbine for all you
turbine noobs out there technically it's
an old technology I mean it dates back
to the Persian Empire or something
we have taken this base design and kind
of brought it to the Modern Age
with modern materials carbon fiber
stainless steel
[Music]
we've made it really really strong we
have engineered and cut the plates so
that the turbo never goes on overspin
and we just done the system so it's
really really simple and therefore we
can keep the price down but it also can
take really really harsh weather
and weather is a serious problem
this is what can happen to a
conventional wind turbine when excessive
wind speeds hit
in Iceland windmills can last for about
three years before the weather does them
in
the shape of the ice wind turbines
allows them to function in low wind and
to stop from spinning out of control in
high wind
and beyond that
they just look cool
people when they look at it they don't
realize what it is
[Music]
they just think it's a sculpture or
something
they're not thinking about this as an
ugly energy production price
so we started putting more emphasis on
the design itself how it looks all the
curves and stuff like that
Iceland has trials running throughout
this country and expects to begin
selling its turbines worldwide later
this year
foreign
is anxious to test out Iceland's
Ingenuity on a bigger stage we've been
isolated for a long time and I think
we're fought for a long time for several
different things and this is just part
of a fighting inventing new things and
going new ways
the truth of the matter is that unlike
most people I didn't visit Iceland to
take in the countryside or find the
first Puffin of the Season all of that
stuff was the garnish on my trip
[Music]
I came here for urban chaos
drunken joy and an explosion of raw
emotions
I came here for the cultural phenomenon
known as Eve band Fest buckle up because
things are about to get weird
really weird
nerds
of them making
an aunt pilgrimage to Reykjavik to
celebrate Eve online a massive
multiplayer online game that takes place
in outer space
for three days The Gamers come together
dress up like their favorite characters
shop from an endless supply of Swag we
should buy one of these and get a sneak
peek of what's on the horizon
there's also a massive live tournament
to decide who will become one of the
main rulers of the eve Universe we shall
coronate our new leader and the losers
shall ritually sacrifice themselves
there's no going to last for much longer
here trading bloat for blown here in the
final match the captain goes down I know
it is
[Applause]
Walk The Halls here and you'll quickly
find yourself face to face with a wide
variety of geek species how many hours
would you play a day I'm logged into Eve
probably six hours a day seven days a
week if I don't have other plans
we're logging in at least two or three
times a week and joining fleets and
killing people
[Music]
it never stops and if you miss a day
then you're going to have to make it up
the next day
[Music]
some people are the nicest people you've
ever met are ruthless like thugs and
bandits
[Music]
at its most basic level Eve online is a
war game set in space
people build their characters from
scratch hop in ships like this band
Together by The Thousands to Forum
armies and fight battles that can take
months even years
you've got its start back in 2003 and
today it's evolved into a vast Universe
nearly as rich and complex as the real
world with a completely developed
political system and social hierarchy
there's a complex economy too based on
billions of transactions and lots of
manual labor all the ships all the
ammunition all the parts of all the
pieces that go on your ship the drones
the guns all of that was built by
someone and since there's a lot of
things in Eve it's huge
before players can zoom off to battle
they must spend weeks mining materials
to build ships and weapons
this Titan is one of the largest class
ships it can take six weeks to make and
is over 8.5 miles long coalitions spend
years obtaining their space gear and
they can lose it all with one bad
decision what's the lowest feeling
you've ever had the lowest feeling I've
ever had was losing my own Titan
there's nothing like losing about six
thousand real world dollars in Virtual
equipment you know in in you know in the
blink of an eye most games of this type
split people up into groups of a couple
thousand players and give everyone
missions to accomplish not Eve from the
outset it's been a game where all of the
players inhabit a single universe and
they collectively decide how the game
should be played
this makes Eve a never-ending story a
spectacular communal experience so all
400 000 some odd people who play this
game we all are playing together you get
to know the same people and we have
space celebrities we have space
politicians people know who they are if
you're a hero or a villain and Eve half
a million people know your name know
your reputation and will either try to
take you down or follow you you know as
a result of that
what's your status lots of games offer
people an escape but none more so than
Eve
the flaccid become great warriors the
shy turn into socialites
Eve is about becoming something bigger
or at least different than what you are
in real life there will be consequences
[Laughter]
hi hi
my name is Charles White I play next
Singularity on EVE Online and uh the
creature I am wearing is an in-game item
okay and it's called a feto okay what's
your role in the game well the because
I'm an older guy I just started giving
advice on on the comms and the players
promoted me to the position of Pope of
Eve online so I became the space Pope I
give blessings I've done two weddings
real world weddings uh I've blessed like
six babies already
I would change a command often goes the
way that I believe most do you will have
wolf pack 10 works as a mechanic by day
but when he logs on he becomes a fleet
commander with hundreds of obedient
soldiers ready to follow his orders I've
personally led a little over 700 some
people have led thousands do you feel
like you have two lives
I don't feel like I had two lives I feel
like I have one life that is very
complicated I try not to separate what I
do in Eve from reality because it has an
impact and at the same time I try not to
let Eve become so real that I give up
things in you know my regular day job
and my life and seeing my real world
friends for a game
[Music]
a few players is obsessive online gaming
nerds
really easy but that would do a
disservice to the depth of the game and
The Fan Fest experience
the bonds that are made and generated
they become members of the kind of like
an extended family I've been here four
times and we see the same guys here like
it's your buddy now because you've been
flying with them for years and coming
here honestly anytime that I get to go
out and just hang out with my nerd
Brethren it's it's been pretty fun
[Music]
I think you'll play Eaves for the rest
of your life probably I don't ever
imagine not playing you so there's
enough in this game to keep you
interested there are so many things I
don't know at this point like if you
asked me about Wormhole space I have no
idea how it works I know they exist I
know I can go through wormholes but I
never lived in there I've never even
seen what you can do in there there's so
much to Eve such a big world to be a
part of
when you're done spending a day hanging
out with your fellow space Warlords
there's only one thing left to do
[Music]
this is a tradition at Fan Fest I think
it starts at nine o'clock ends at five
but we'll see if we make it watching
these Gamers party with each other
something I'll never forget
but there's something so human and
endearing about seeing people in their
element feeling free to express
themselves and damn it it's hard not to
join in having met some of the eve
players you may have noticed a trend the
game tends to attract smart passionate
often devious people
managing these people is hard sort of
like hurting deranged cats that have
been doing lots of drugs for 13 years
this management burden has been the job
of CCP games the Icelandic game Studio
that invented Eve
since Eve has few rules CCP has had to
work hand in hand with the players to
shape the game and introduce new stuff
to buy and new places to go
some of the key input from both sides
arrives at Fan Fest where important
things like Wormhole territory get
debated are you
concerned about how hard it is for us to
roll wormholes at this point do you feel
like it's about the right balance the
depth of this two-way relationship is
unique in the gaming industry
welcome to IFA Fest 2016.
one of the key people who shaped the
vision of Eve is ccp's longtime CEO
Hilmar Peterson
Hilmar is something of a philosopher
when it comes to Iceland science fiction
and the role that Eve may play in
nothing less than the evolution of the
human species
why does it make so much sense that this
game started in Iceland when you're a
kid in Iceland you develop a clear sense
that the country is here to kill you and
if you don't pay attention you're just
gonna die
where you have volcanoes and blizzards
and avalanches and God knows what
you really have to band together against
the elements
[Music]
Eve started out from humble beginnings
on computer savvy icelanders raised the
money to build Eve by selling a board
game called hedgefield where the danger
game in English which ended up being a
Smash Hit
[Music]
funds in hand they leapt from the dining
room table to the Stars building a
beautiful and iconic interpretation of
life in space
Hilmar sees it Eve might now provide a
road map for an Interstellar Society
we very much think about the game as a
construct to
inspire the Manifest Destiny of mankind
which is to grow Beyond this planet
so we kind of look at the online the
closest thing you have today to live in
space
so and we believe by giving hundreds of
thousands and millions of people that
experience and that dream we will bring
closer to us the the desire and drive to
make it actually concretely happen
it's a new game called Valkyrie
pure blow Em Up High action space war
game built for the virtual reality
headsets just coming to Market
investors have recently poured money
into CCP betting that it will figure out
how to merge the best parts of Eve and
Valkyrie and create the first meaningful
virtual social network
where do you see all this technology
heading
what we wanted to do with Valkyrie was
to do something way more immersive
something like immediately impactful on
your kind of emotional state take them
down Nice Shot nice job all right
if there's that differently because it's
more slow paced and methodical there's
more to your brain than to your heart
and ultimately the dream is to kind of
merge these two concepts
[Music]
no more didn't invade Eve
but this guy did he's Rainier Hardison
one of the three co-creators of the game
he explained the origins of Eve to me
near a monument located beside the
Reykjavik Marina
it was built to honor the eve players
with their gamer handles etched into the
base
all during Fan Fest people come to find
their names and pay homage to the game
people feel very passionate about this
and this strange thing about it when you
when you log into it it doesn't feel
like you're playing a game it feels like
you're logging into a real world and
these people feel it too and the reason
is because it's it's really about human
you know it's about humans interacting
it's about human emotion and you know
whatever makes us human why do you think
we will get all that at their jobs and
then come and work another job and seek
to feel that at home after
I would say it's kind of a you know it's
in a strange Twisted way it's a it's a
utopian perfect world
it's written with warrant strife and
everything but everyone can you know
aspire to to be something big
very end of Fan Fest
ECP employees celebrate
with a raucous party at the harpa
concert hall
it's one final booze and heavy metal
infused time together
before they go home and return to the
doldrums of regular life
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lyrical quality to so much
about this place to the way people weave
stories into their daily lives to the
way in which they seem to celebrate
suffering and to the way in which they
approach technology and fold it into
their culture
this country is a testament to the
Triumph of the human will and to the
power of imagination
it's the kind of place where the
surroundings beg you to get lost in your
thoughts and then smile deep down in
your soul
[Music]
this fall breaks out in Canada I'm
reminded of all the beauty innocence and
gun-free fun available from our
neighbors to the north
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's the Majesty of Toronto
[Applause]
vast hockey race
[Applause]
and gallons of maple syrup that you can
chug openly and guilt-free for this
maple syrup is pure and nourishing
[Applause]
changing of the seasons also happens to
be the perfect time to encounter one of
Canada's most prized creatures
the artificial intelligence nerd
ever since people first came up with the
idea of computers they've dreamed of
imbuing them with artificial
intelligence
I am a smart
I have a very fine brain that's the most
remarkable thing I've ever seen
the AI is just a computer that is able
to mimic or simulate uh human thought or
human behavior within that there's a
subset called machine learning that it's
now the underpinning of what is most
exciting about AI
by allowing computers to learn how to
solve problems on their own machine
learning has made a series of
breakthroughs that once seemed nearly
impossible
it's the reason computers can understand
your voice spot a friend's face in a
photo and steer a card
and it's the reason people are actively
talking about the arrival of human-like
AI
and whether that would be a good thing
for a horrific end of days thing
many people made this moment possible
but one figure Towers Above the Rest
I've come to the University of Toronto
to see the man they call the Godfather
of modern artificial intelligence
Jeff Hinton
[Music]
because of a back condition Jeff Hinton
hasn't been able to sit down for more
than 12 years
I hate standing I'd much rather say time
but if I sit down I have a distance
sorry well at least now standing desks
are fashionable and yeah but I was ahead
I was standing where I was standing when
they were the fashionable
can't sit in the car or on a bus Hinton
walks everywhere
the walk says a lot about Hinton and his
resolved
for nearly 40 years Hinton has been
trying to get computers to learn like
people do a quest almost everyone
thought was crazy or at least hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field
Google thinks this is the future of the
company Amazon thinks the fusion company
Apple thinks his future company my own
Department thinks this does probably
nonsense who we shouldn't be doing
anymore
so I took everybody into it except my
own Department
Chef Hansen pretty early on became
obsessed with this idea of figuring out
how the mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain worked then
he got into psychology and then finally
he settled on more of a computer science
approach to modeling the brain and got
into artificial intelligence
feeling is if you want to understand a
really complicated device like a brain
you should build one
I mean you could look at cars and you
could think you could understand cars
when you try and build a car you
suddenly discover that there's this
stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work yeah
as Jeff was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some AI
researchers across the pond
Frank rosenblatt
50s developed what he called a
perceptron and it was a neural network a
Computing system that would mimic the
brain
the basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons these are little
Computing units but they're actually
modeled on the way that the human brain
does its computation
they take incoming data like we do from
our senses and they actually learn so
the neural net can learn to make
decisions over time
blood's Hope was that you could feed a
neural network a bunch of data like
pictures of men and women and it would
eventually learn how to tell them apart
just like humans do
there was just one problem
it didn't work very well
rosenblatt his neural network was the
single layer of neurons
and it was limited in what it could do
extremely Limited
and a colleague of his wrote a book in
the late 60s that showed these
limitations
and it kind of put the whole area of
research into a deep freeze for a good
10 years
no one wanted to work in this area they
were sure it would never work
well almost no one
it was just obvious to me that it was
the right way to go
the brain's a big neural network and so
it has to be that stuff like this can
work because it works in our brains
but there's just never any doubt about
that you know what do you think it was
inside of you that
kept you wanting to pursue this when
everyone else was giving up just that
you thought it was the right direction
to go now that everyone else was wrong
okay
Hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural Nets might work and he's
going to pursue it no matter what
for a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the U.S
he kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the defense department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go
he suddenly hears the Canada might be
interested in funding artificial
intelligence and that was very
attractive that I could go off to this
civilized town and just get on with it
so I came to the University of Toronto
and then in the mid-80s we discovered
how to remain more complicated neural
Nets so they could solve those problems
that the simple ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layered neural network a deep
neural network
and this started to work in a lot of
ways but again they hit a ceiling
[Music]
through the 90s into the 2000s Jeff was
one of only a handful of people on the
planet who are still pursuing this
technology
good morning he would show up at
academic conferences and be banished to
the back rooms he was treated as really
like a pariah
but Jeff was consumed by this and
couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn until about 2006
when the world catches up to hinton's
ideas
[Music]
competed with Arnold Foster and now he's
behaving like I thought it would behave
in the mid 80s it's solving everything
the arrival of super fast chips and the
massive amounts of data produced on the
internet gave hinton's algorithms a
magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image then they could
recognize speech and translate from one
language to another
by 2012 words like neural Nets and
machine learning were popping up on the
front page of the New York Times
next up we have Professor Jeffrey Hinton
of the University of Toronto
thank you
[Applause]
for hits in this is obviously a really
Redemptive moment
now he's basically a technology
celebrity
and for Canada it's the country's moment
as well
they have more AI researchers than just
about any other place on the planet and
the quest now is to see what these guys
can do starting companies and pushing
the technology forward
I'm going to set out on a journey across
Canada to see the best in Canadian AI
technology and to get a feel for how far
the technology has come and how far it
still has to go
[Music]
here is a city that gets right at the
central tension of Modern Life
and the unfolding AI Revolution
[Applause]
it's Montreal a place filled with beauty
and Old World charms
that asked you to move slowly through
its streets
[Music]
chill for a while
reflect and think Deep Thoughts
at the same time it's one of the world's
top AI research centers students flock
here from all over the globe to get deep
with machine learning and to take Jeff
hinton's ideas and figure out how to
turn them into products we all use
to see just how successful they've been
look no further than your pocket
all this stuff started out as hardcore
computer science but over the last five
years AI has invaded our everyday lives
your smartphone is packed full of AI
powered apps including something like
Google translate that lets you point
your phone at a magazine that's written
in French and read it as if you were a
local
Engineers have been trying to get
computers to translate text like this
for decades but it was Jeff's neural
Nets that finally made it possible
thanks Jeff
and it's not just your smartphone
neural networks are heading for the open
road off we go
be my friend Stefan the head of
Montreal's Tesla fan club
I'm driving a Tesla for a little bit
more than four years so you have people
asking you for rides all the time yes
maybe that's because of his Fancy Pants
autopilot
Tesla's semi-autonomous driving system
that kicks in when road conditions are
right
so that's it autopilot's on yes and it's
driving by itself
so we need to pay attention
but we don't have to drive
yeah it's crazy
self-driving cars are packed full of
cameras sensors and radar when teamed
with computer vision neural Nets it's
this technology that lets the cars build
a picture of the world
the technology has a long way to go but
this Tesla can monitor all the cars
around it switch lanes and park all by
itself
thanks Jeff so you're living in the
future yeah you know when you try it
once it's very difficult to do without
it because I just can be relaxed
and we can drive like this
there's a stop sign so that's why we
still need to pay attention
[Music]
a big part of hinton's Legacy lies
Beyond these examples of AI in the world
he's also inspired a legion of disciples
spreading the good word of neural Nets
yahshua bengio is a professor at the
University of Montreal
he's one of the researchers who glommed
on to hinton's ideas when it seemed to
make little sense to do so
[Music]
and together they've come up with many
of the key Concepts behind modern AI
you guys worked on this stuff through
the 80s 90s the 2000s and then it just
seemed like this totally went from
computer science and research to we see
it everywhere in our lives are you know
or even you surprised what's happened
the last five years that it really is
like sitting on all our phones and the
rate at which the progress and the
Industrial Products have been coming out
is totally something we didn't expect
even now it's hard to predict where are
we going is it going to slow down
or are we going to continue with this
exponential increase
it's thanks to yahshua that Montreal is
full of top-notch AI graduate Talent
in turn has brought Tech giants like
Google and Facebook to tell along with
their ample checkbooks
[Music]
to me it seems like if you're good at AI
you can make two three hundred thousand
dollars a year this is crazy to see how
much these guys get paid now a million
dollars is something quite common as a
salary have you ever had a country offer
you an incredible amount of money to
come set up a lab there not a country
but yeah companies yeah foreign
has rejected the lucrative offers of big
neural net
he remains committed to the Ivory Towers
of Academia which is a better fit for
his philosophical approach to AI
you've got guys like Elon Musk and
Stephen Hawking that sometimes paint
this technology in a very very dark
light that it could run amok and start
doing things on its own but you know
what do you feel when you hear people
say things like that I'm not concerned
about technology running amok of the
Terminator scenario I think is not very
credible and I also believe that if
we're able to build machines that are as
smart as us they also smart enough to
understand our values and to understand
our moral system and and so I in a way
that's good for us now I think there are
real concerns which is essentially
misuse of AI to influence people's minds
it's already happening with the
political advertising yeah I mean we've
already seen like the stuff from
Facebook so I think we should be careful
about this
and try to regulate the use of AI in
places where it's morally wrong
ethically wrong I think we just should
just ban it and make it you know illegal
it's comforting that yahshua has these
concerns
but hop down the road from the
University in reality but what's left of
it becomes Messier
this tiny room is the home to a startup
called lyreburg
it was founded by yahshua's former
students and has built an app that can
clone your voice
are you speaking about this new
algorithm to copy voices this is huge it
can make us say anything now really
anything
[Music]
one of its founders
Mexican Pat Jose
he taught me the art of the club
so you'll need to record yourself for a
few minutes of audio
thousands of letters danced across the
amateur author's screen
when you start to eat like this
something is the matter
you guys better quit politics and take
in washing
I don't know where that one came from
okay so create my digital voice now
creating your digital voice takes at
least one minute one minute my God yeah
so before to create some artificial
voice of someone you would need to
record yourself for at least eight hours
test your voice all right so now I get
the types of the yeah so the moment of
the truth okay
Birds AI
is
Magic
after I'm done typing oh I'm gonna spell
better any words I put into the app can
be played back in my digital voice
and here's the crazy thing even words I
never actually said in the first place
artificial intelligence technology seems
to be advancing very quickly should we
be afraid
I mean I can definitely hear my voice in
there that's that is that's really
interesting I just picked those words at
random and I definitely did not say some
of them and it's like Flawless and being
able to sort of pick from just about any
word and manufacture it
[Music]
hello world is the best Joy I have ever
seen
[Music]
this technology seems sweet
lends itself to all manner of trickery
[Applause]
I've popped back to my hotel to test out
the library technology a little bit and
you can see some really obvious ways
that this could be abused this is this
is fake Donald Trump talking
the United States is considering in
addition to other options stopping all
trade with any country doing business
with North Korea and then you could
picture somebody taking over your voice
and creating some Mayhem in your
personal life now to really put my
computer voice to the test I am going to
call my dear sweet mother and see if she
recognizes me
ah what are you guys up to today
I have any electricity early this
morning and we're just hanging around
the house I'm just finishing up work and
waiting for the boys to get home
I think I'm coming down with a virus oh
wow you
why
you
I was messing around with you you were
talking to a computer
is that scary or good
it's scary if it was something really
important I do now isn't it I don't know
it sounds like you is it yes
[Music]
the real artificial intelligence weirdos
in Canada live here
in Edmonton
[Music]
this is a large but very very cold and
very very flat city that is more or less
in the middle of nowhere
it's the kind of place that has a giant
butter vault
five the lean winter months
[Music]
on how these conditions bring out
interesting traits in people
ask anyone like this guy from the
Edmondson tourist center well Edmonton's
uh one of those cities that isn't you
know automatically listed in the top
cities in Canada in terms of size or
scale or or notice even but it's always
had a really neat quality to it of that
Western independent spirit that you see
very much in in Alberta in general
combined with a conscience and a
thoughtfulness
over at the University of Alberta some
of the most far out AI research in the
world is taking place
the man I'm here to see is the
University's very own AI Godfather Rich
Sutton
rich is considered one of the great
revolutionary thinkers in AI
if you are not Canadian I am Canadian
but not by birth uh no I was born in the
U.S but now I'm just Canadian okay and
what brought you to Canada the politics
I wanted to get away from difficult
times in the United States the United
States was invading other countries in
2003 when I came here and I didn't care
for all that thank you
Sutton entered the field of AI in the
mid-80s and like Jeff Hinton and Joshua
bengio he was a big believer in neural
networks
but Sutton has a different idea about
how to further the technology
unlike Henson's method of feeding neural
networks Reams and reams of data and
telling them what to do Sutton wants
them to learn more naturally from
experience an approach called
reinforcement learning
well reinforcement learning it's like
what animals do and what people do we
try several things the things that work
best you keep doing those and things
that don't work out so well you stop
doing them and how do you teach a
computer
all you need is a sense the computer has
to have a sense of what's good and
what's bad
and so you give it a special signal
called the reward if the reward is high
that means it's good the word is low
that means it's bad
see reinforcement learning in action I
found Marlos an industrious young
Brazilian who's created an AI to play
his video games for him his algorithm
plays the game thousands of times and
gradually learns from experience how to
do better
so the goal of this game is that you are
this yellow blob then what you have to
do is that you have to get as many
potions as you can while avoiding
harpies
and this is like the AI going at this
for the first time it's day I run it for
the first time so it just bumps into
things if it gets points it's happy if
it dies it's unhappy yes
and the AI starts to figure out that
maybe what I want to do is to collect
these potions and avoid the harpies and
now we can look at AI that has ran for
5000 games okay and this is what it
looks like
you can tell that it's smarter about its
strategy yes and then what happens if
you run it 500 000 times oh we we got
you the Superhuman performance level
[Applause]
though notching a high score is the
noblest of Pursuits reinforcement
learning has turned out to have all
kinds of other applications
it's behind the algorithm that
recommends movies and TV shows on
Netflix and Amazon
it beat the world champion go player a
feat previously thought impossible for a
computer
soon it could read your brain waves and
determine whether you have a mental
disorder
but for Sutton all that is just the
beginning we are trying to make real
intelligence we're trying to recreate
human intelligence humans are our
example he sees reinforcement learning
as the path to what futurists call The
Singularity the moment when our AI
Creations light up and surge past human
level intelligence
do you have a date for The Singularity
or so they give you uh it's a it's a
quite broad probability distribution in
the median is it 2040. that means equal
chance of being before or after 2040.
okay the rationale goes like this uh by
2030 we'll have the hardware
so give guys like me another 10 years to
figure out
the algorithms yeah software to go with
the hardware to do it
it's going to be exciting where we're
going
if 2040 seems like a long time to wait
to meet a smart robot do not fret
over in the experimental wing of the
University there are coeds hard at work
blurring the line between humans and
machines
are you human
[Music]
edmontonian genius Corey Mathewson tell
me about this guy a little bit or yeah
sure so this is blueberry on blueberry
I've deployed The Improv system so
there's an artificial improv system
running on blueberry right now
yes that's right Corey does improv
comedy with a robot
I've been doing improv longer than I've
been doing Computing science I've been
doing it for 12 years and I thought you
know there's no more natural convergence
than taking some of these
state-of-the-art systems and putting
them up on stage
[Music]
the moon and the Universe
I can't think it was like a
ventriloquist sort of this is like a new
age
that's a really good way yeah strange
Twist on it the piece that's different
is that I don't know what it will say
blueberry I I created you I downloaded a
voice into your brain so that you could
perform in front of these people
to give blueberry the power of surreal
Canadian improv Corey made use of some
tech that should be familiar by now
a neural network
step one he feeds the network the
dialogue from a bunch of movies
102 000 movies to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years and that's just so it can learn
language see how somebody responds to
somebody else that's exactly right yeah
it builds kind of a language model
[Music]
he uses
running to train the network
[Music]
British
time to put this wannabe kid in the hall
to the test there we go start
improvising
okay campers we're gonna get ready for a
real baseball game grab your gloves and
grab your baseball bats let's get out
there especially you Franklin
of course I will not be much longer okay
okay well why aren't you ready for the
match
come on Franklin you know how I feel
about you but you got to keep your head
in the game right now
[Music]
oh Jesus put down the bat Franklin what
are you doing you have nothing to hide
that song I've got nothing to hide look
this is all I am okay
that's great that's how it works
obviously some of the responses are a
little bit weird but then it's really
funny because then as you're going along
it did hit a couple things perfectly and
and then it's like yeah I mean it's
extra hilarious because of course yeah
now it's going
blueberry may not be ready for its
Second City audition just yet
but Corey has a higher purpose making AI
relatable
there is a fear in society of AI
so we are kind of humanizing this AI
where we're taking it down a peg we're
saying don't be afraid of this Tech look
at how cute it is look at how kind of
naive it is
filters you've done it again blueberry
yes
isn't there a flip side to that though
then you make it cute and and then
people start to accept it and you know
then then we wake up and I mean I I
don't think that will happen in my time
you may be near
not so near
evidence of this oddly beautiful place
keep pushing the technology they just
might create something alarmingly
human-like one day
for Rich Sutton it's not a question of
whether we'll get there but weather will
be able to accept our mechanized
brethren
our society will be will be challenged
you know it's just like every time you
know our black people people are women
people we will do the same thing with
robots eventually uh are they allowed to
own property are they allowed to earn an
income or do they have to be owned by
somebody but a robot's obviously about a
person
laughs
right
no
[Music]
for my last stop I returned to Toronto
home to 2.8 million people one very tall
tower and of course the Godfather
himself inside the system there's lots
of little processes which are a little
bit like brain cells they work he may be
an import but Jeff Hinton has done
something truly exceptional for Toronto
he's turned this city into an AI Mecca
where AI conferences like this one seem
to take place daily we are enormously
thankful to Canadians for inventing all
this stuff because we now use it
throughout our entire business record
that he owns that Google owes Canada
that was a mistake
the tech industry is full of people who
adore AI
[Music]
it's like Elon mus K even Hawking who
said well today I might be the end of us
consider such dystopia in the proper
light
I've come to Toronto's geekiest bar
hello George to encase myself in this
steel container with George divorceki
he's a writer for Gizmodo and an AI
philosopher
people since we're in the apocalyptic
bar what is the the con case around AI
what what's what's the nastiest scenario
that everybody's worried about
unfortunately there's there's no
shortage of nasty scenarios and this I
think this is what makes artificial
intelligence such a scary thing is all
the different ways that it can go wrong
it can be everything from an accident
you know where we just didn't think it
through we gave a very powerful computer
instructions to do something we thought
we explained it articulately we thought
we gave it a concrete goal and it
completely took a different path than we
thought it would in such a way that it
actually caused some great damage
I'm sure you've heard the old paper clip
example where your paper clip
manufacturer and you say hey we need
lots of paper clips and because the
artificial intelligence has so much
reach and so much power it actually
starts to go about converting all of the
matter and all the molecules on the
planet into paper clips before you know
it we've now converted the entire Cosmos
into paperclips
it's a crazy scenario but it's an
illustrative scenario we can't be
dismissive of the perils I think that's
exceptionally dangerous and I don't
think it's too early to start raising
the alarm Bells about it
being turned into clippy sounds awful
but fear not we'll have years to ease
into that sort of suffering
as AI steadily plucks off one job after
another
[Music]
the first to go of course will likely be
the always screwed Factory workers
which brings us to Suzanne gildert
a budding AI Overlord and founder of
robotic startup Kindred AI
[Music]
tell me about these guys so these are
research prototypes
so they're some of the first robots we
built at Kindred
they tend to work with small robots it's
a bit like if you imagine a child
growing up and it breaks a lot of things
now imagine if the child was six feet
tall when it had the brain of a
six-month-old it would be a terrible
terribly dangerous how many of these
robots have ever slapped you I I have
been hit in the face by robots a couple
of times and it's that way Suzanne seems
nice enough
she makes exotic digital art
and she loves cats to the point where
she's built a robotic Fleet of them for
the office
one I believe it's called pinkfoot
it's a quadruped robot Loosely based on
a cat anatomy although it's not a very
highly faithful representation yet
and then when you were growing up you
would build things as well yeah that's
correct yeah
so I was really enthralled by
Electronics it
I guess most little girls would be
looking at trays of beads and things and
I was looking at trays of like resistors
and capacitors and little components but
having the same kind of reaction to them
[Music]
but don't be fooled by the hobby
electronics and the cute catbots
[Music]
uzan is a keen businesswoman
and Kindred has recently embarked on its
first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running uh picking up
objects these would run all day all day
all night
powered by neural network These Arms can
do something that's very easy for a
human but very hard for a bot
pick up objects of different shapes and
put them down
most factories still use people to do
that sort of thing lots and lots of
people today everyone's shopping on
e-commerce thousands and thousands of
different types of objects shapes
textures weights how do you pick that up
right now as humans you have millions of
humans in warehouses just like picking
up things and putting it into another
location so we're teaching our robots
how to do that
oh what's the hard part it's figuring
out what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it yeah exactly it's
very hard to pick it up right so so
things will show up in any shape right
and you got to figure out how to pick it
up without dropping it
put it in the location so it takes a lot
of training
part of that training involves of all
things humans
robot pilots who manually control the
arms while the AI watches and learns the
finer points of grabbing
[Music]
is there something Grim about the human
training there and yeah it's not good to
take people's jobs away but this kind of
Technology coming into the workforce
should make us start thinking about how
we're going to pay people in the future
because AI is not just going to automate
you know manual labor jobs it's going to
automate things like doctors and lawyers
and accountants very soon so I think
there's going to be issues there's going
to be a lot of disruption
Suzanne is a realist
but she's also an optimist
vision of the future robots won't be
mindless competitors to Human
citizens like the rest of us one of the
crazy ideas that you talk about was
you've got a robot and it's working in a
factory and then it's got to go maybe it
gets paid a wage and it goes to buy
lithium ion batteries to keep it going
why would that have to happen I mean if
you're having a physical body they will
have a lot of physical needs just like
we have
you might have to go to the repair shop
to get like a motor look tab or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that I think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to explore new things they've never
seen before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to perhaps rest so that
their mind has time to consolidate all
this new information so if you've tried
to picture it in my head this is the
robot workers they go home and sit on
the couch and watch TV after work it is
I don't see why not I probably watch cat
videos
it's hard to tell sometimes if Suzanne
is laughing with us they're at us
but she's not alone in her cautious
optimism for the future
there's always a sense that you know
technology can be either used for good
or used for bad I'm reassured that that
Canada is part of it in terms of trying
to set us on the right path
on the whole being responsible and
thoughtful about the power we're gaining
by research and learning is the right
trend line and I don't think ai's
automatically doomed to some dystopian
outcome
[Music]
we're told that politicians will come up
with policies that address massive job
loss and prevent horrific inequality
between the classes
and we're told that these guys will take
so long to become human-like that we
need not be afraid for a while
[Applause]
the truth though is that we're turning
ourselves over to the unknown here
so you know fingers crossed
eventually I think we will become the
AIS we will become the intelligent
machines
we will understand how things can be
smart and we can deliberately create
them
so it's you might think of it as making
a new generation new kinds of people
humanity is continuing to evolve and why
wouldn't enhanced people or even design
people be the next step in humanity
it's really hard to predict the future
I think there's going to be all sorts of
things happen we didn't expect
[Music]
but there's one thing that we can
predict
this technology is going to change
everything
[Music]
hi
goodbye good night goodbye
once I power you down that's it
I'll never you again
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this place
seems like make-believe
or perhaps the fever dream of a design
blogger
no one in their right mind would build a
hotel in a forest
you can stick the rooms up in some trees
but then again
it sort of fits perfectly
because this is Sweden and The Treehouse
Hotel oozes sweet
it's nature fornicating with functional
design and creative thinking this is the
UFO and really this is why we came to
Sweden to get Wi-Fi out here
from Stockholm to the Arctic Circle
swedes have pumped out dazzling Tech
infused products that put a new Twist on
what it means to be modern entertaining
and useful
okay here's what you probably know about
Stockholm
it's beautiful
it's full of gorgeous unassuming people
and it's almost disturbingly clean what
you don't know about Stockholm is that
outside of Silicon Valley it's the world
leader in fostering Tech addiction
Spotify Skype and the makers of
Minecraft and Candy Crush all got their
start here
the swedes
the supposedly cool passion challenge
people know how to tap into our desires
and make simple things we can't escape
[Music]
I started my journey at epicenter a nerd
Lounge located in the heart of Stockholm
any place trying to establish its Tech
cred needs a spot like this people come
here to fiddle with their robots hash
out their techno-utopian fantasies over
beer and if they're totally nuts insert
a chip underneath the skin on their
wrists that lets them open the epicenter
door
hello there my name is Phil hat about
those robots
[Music]
my reptile brand is telling me that this
thing is alive
and then my intellect tells me no I know
it's just a piece of plastic and some
software
we've stumbled upon something really
super interesting I think
[Music]
they're trying to make mechanical
creatures and computer interfaces appear
and act more like humans hi my name is
Ashley hello Ashley nice to meet you I
am a socially intelligent robot it's
nice to meet you as well nice shirt
thank you we want to build a system that
can interact very fluently with humans
understand their social signals their
emotions their attention States
there's a phenomenon known as The
Uncanny Valley
it's that queasy feeling you get when a
robot or computer interface looks real
but not real enough
the brain's behind fur hat these two
hardcore academics think they're on
their way to solving that problem and
making robots less nauseating we come
from a background of human human
communication understand how humans
interact with each other is this social
layer that is on top of the typical AI
if they can push the technology forward
fur hat could end up as the face of Siri
or Amazon's Alexa it might keep Lonely
People company do you think I look good
or be the thing you yell at when
checking in for a flight at the airport
can you walk us through like each little
piece
of course for that is a main piece here
she's got a hat and a wig and a skull
and a mouse as far as robots go fur
Hat's design is really simple it's as
easy as taking a mask on and off and
then the mask is magnetically attached
so you can unplug the mouse
and then you can attach the different
mask with different personality to it
and then it needs to be calibrated so
that you can get the right I do want to
see the alien baby what did you say
there is a facial animation system you
know like the ones you do you have in
games and animated movies yeah so it's
all software based and then we use a
micro projector to project that
animation onto a mask so you get very
accurate eye movement gestures facial
expressions lip animation I can look
like a woman and sound like a woman like
an avatar
that's that was pretty good
but I think the world has been really
waiting for robots at home to interact
with you know to see them in a human
natural habitat where we don't see any
robots at the moment one day fur hat
might read bedtime stories to your kid
I'd say it's at the nightmare stage of
that Journey but the product has gone on
sale for use by universities which are
busy tweaking it to ensure sweet dreams
in the years to come
you're boring why would you say that to
me you would look strange or to sling
insults at handsome TV hosts how about
beer
Sweden's rise as a tech power did not
happen by accident the country's
Advanced industrialization is due
largely to Swedish inventions like the
dial telephone and to high standards in
engineering starting in the late 1990s
the government made a huge investment in
Broadband laying Fiber Optic Cables
throughout the country then it began
subsidizing PCS so every citizen could
have a modern computer with a super fast
internet connection but this wasn't all
about making a sterile nerd Factory the
swedes also designed their education
system to emphasize creativity and
experimentation and to mix the Arts and
Sciences one curious offshoot of the
social engineering was that Sweden
created a nation of pirates
that generation of tech infused
youngsters set out to Pirate software
music movies anything really and did so
with astonishing skill file sharing
services like Kaza and uTorrent started
here and so did an entire political
party literally called the pirate party
one of the Pirates was this bald Beauty
Daniel Eck hey man hey great to see you
nice to see you back ran uTorrent and
ended up on the wrong side of the music
labels then he pulled a 180 and decided
to try and become the music industry's
Savior by starting a new less Steely
company Spotify it was Swedish
Simplicity the turned Spotify into a
huge hit people could find stream and
download songs with such ease that
neither consumers nor the labels could
resist the service
almost every morning X stops off at
saturnus a trendy Cafe in the ooster mom
neighborhood of Stockholm
he engages in fika a Swedish snacking
ritual that takes place a few times a
day
should we dig in yeah dig in please
you like him but it was good it's it's
um seems more wholesome than like a
Cinnabon yeah
so you got it set off on the path of
doing Tech and music so really the only
thing that was important in my family
was that you learn how to play music I
got a guitar when I was like three four
okay but yeah I got the computer when I
was like five and uh for me like in the
beginning it was really all about games
and just fun playing from that point I I
kind of realized like hey these games
are boring how hard would it be to try
to fix the game yeah
um and so I started coding games when I
was like seven or eight or something
like that it's kind of amazing that
you've been on this trajectory yeah you
know your whole life yeah I've never had
a normal job when I grew up like I
didn't realize how you made money
starting something yourself or investing
money or like that was just a totally
foreign concept
outside of Silicon Valley Sweden has the
highest per capita number of unicorns
which are startups valued over one
billion dollars there's a tension that
comes with all this new money and fame
like much of Scandinavia Sweden operates
under a cultural code of conduct known
as yantela it's a philosophy that
demands people not think too highly of
themselves I was wondering if people
recognize you out on the street
um yeah I mean they do but because this
is like Sweden no one really comes up
except if it's like 10 p.m and they've
had a beer or two cut to 2016 in this
way of living finds itself in conflict
with tech millionaires boozing it up at
clubs and hyping their tight little apps
act knows the situation as well as
anyone
you know by the time you're 21 I mean
you were a millionaire essentially right
because you had sold a couple businesses
and done very well for yourself and then
it sounds like you went through sort of
a period where
I don't know if showing off is the right
word but you were living oh yeah going
to clubs and I was driving fast cars and
when I looked back to it I'm sort of
almost ashamed of myself because it was
like you know it was
um uh today I realized that it was a
huge sort of period of insecurity
um
it was a lot of fun don't get me wrong
um but it's it's like not who I am and I
never know like as an outsider if we
make too much of all this but this idea
that um you don't want to stand out in
Sweden or Scandinavia and you do stand
out when you when you start making
billions of dollars it's kind of hard to
uh yeah but it is changing I mean if you
walk around in the city now like I see
like Ferraris Lamborghinis like there's
quite a lot of that here which is not
really part of what the fabric of how it
used to be okay
to really contemplate yantullah I took
part in another Swedish tradition known
as standing pensively against a wall
completely aware that I was being
photographed for my own TV show where
Are you supposed to put your head up
here are some of the rules of yantela
[Music]
you are not to think you are anything
special you are not to think you're as
good as we are you're not to think
you're smarter than we are you're not to
convince yourself that you're better
than we are you're not to think you know
more than we do not to think you're more
important than you're not to think
you're good at anything you're not to
laugh at us you're not to think anyone
cares about you you're not to think you
can teach us anything
ah that was refreshing
with the brainwashing portion of the
program over
it was time to live a little
we decided to get out of the cold dine
at a traditional Swedish restaurant and
hit the town
it'll be just about me getting you guys
lost I'm Ashley thank you Henry all
right nice to meet you man from America
oh promised country
I'll tell you this about yatala it gives
way after a few cocktails I'm going to
mix this with the lemon and uh I don't
know what it's called in Sweden they
call it yeah
and that's when the other part of the
Swedish character the friendly joyful
lubricated part goes on full display
foreign
near the end of the night it was time
for my famous disappearing cigarette
magic trick
[Music]
I guess it and my man bun need some work
[Music]
as the startup scene is in Stockholm
Sweden's technology muscle lies in the
northern part of the country
had 560 miles up from Stockholm and
you'll end up in lulio a picturesque
city of 70 000 people wedged between the
Gulf of Bosnia and the Arctic Circle
for centuries lulio has been a cultural
and economic Hub of this region but what
really has lulio buzzing these days is
the arrival of Facebook which opened a
data center on the outskirts of the city
in 2013. at 300 000 square feet it's one
of the largest computer centers ever
built
a place you need a bike and a picnic
lunch to explore fully and while you're
on that picnic lunch you can take a
selfie and post it here cool it's nice
to see you again hi Ashley welcome to
lilio thank you and welcome to Facebook
Joel shelgren has managed the operations
at the lulio data plant since it opened
he offered to show us the guts of this
beastly building
some people think the cloud is actually
a cloud
for others it's an ethereal mystery the
place where your photos and documents
get sucked to and hang out
this though
is the cloud
at least the physical manifestation of
it
it's thousands of servers and storage
systems working together to hold our
information Mrs we're all the action
happens these are all our photos are
like sorry this is really where Facebook
is actually running
look around see over there it's a
picture of a young Ashley Vance who
thought that going blonde would be a
good idea and that one it's a lingering
poke from your creepy EX
and right there is an inspirational meme
helping lift people's Spirits where does
my mom find all these amazing quotes
and because we've built the
infrastructure to be so redundant we can
basically pull any server and it's not
going to affect any end user in any
negative way so we pulled one out here
okay so we're going to take down
Facebook
[Laughter]
typical Monday morning but it's all
built to be as energy and cooling
efficient as possible so there are no
fans at all on this one as you can see
they're sort of it's just working on the
pressure difference that forces the air
through I think for most people who've
never been to a data center they're
usually like these big sort of pizza box
shaped things with tons of fans and
moving Parts going on them and you guys
compacted everything down if the
industry in general started adopting a
lot more of this thinking it could
really change the whole industry and not
just Facebook
couple of corridors will go through a
typical data center relies on massive
air conditioning units to pump cool air
onto tens of thousands of computers
look Facebook is too hip for that
you're gonna catch up it uses Cool
Arctic air to keep its photo friend and
light machines from melting down this
whole place lends itself to Sweden's
meticulous attention to detail and
design the building is an engineering
Marvel that treats air like a Pampered
Corgi poo the air gets sucked in cleaned
watered and then sent on its way VIA
physics with the building pressure
pushing the air down onto the computers
since Facebook gives away its service
for free this place needs to operate as
smoothly and cheaply as possible to
minimize the cost of each click off
camera you'll readily brags about
Facebook's cheap clicks on camera
yantela so we kind of been dodging
around the point I mean this may be the
world's most efficient power efficient
data center I
think one of the most
Swedish modesty
[Music]
it's not just free cold air that brought
Facebook to the Arctic Circle The Social
Network also came for the cheap reliable
power produced by Sweden's vast set of
hydroelectric dams
foreign starting in 1910 the swedes
began building a network of two dozen
hydroelectric dams along the lullet
River
today the dams provide more than enough
power to meet all of Northern Sweden's
needs so now we will start to urinate
Lula River on ludel River Power Rick
Abramson and Christopher Lundgren work
for vodden fall the energy giant that
runs the dams they were kind enough to
take me on a road trip to see up close
how these amazing machines work
[Music]
these guys insist that it's wonderful
living in the great Frigid North
they can check out the Northern Lights
from their hot tubs spend months in
total darkness and hunt bears and moose
so Rick did you already go moose hunting
this year then the small hunting ground
where I'm part of there's only one
grown-up and one cough and the first
morning 30 minutes into the hunt they
shot the big one
then something is over that everyone's
done
walk me through again like how many dams
there are along Jason will do that we
have 15 power stations along this uh
River of course with great power comes
great responsibility and you know stuff
to placate people that care about nature
and fish we're one of the largest fish
breeders in Sweden to compensate for the
fact that we built all the power
stations because the settlement cannot
sort of pass through the river system
now so the Energy company breeds salmon
yeah we do how many would you have to
put back in for years in the Lulu River
we put back close to half a million
every year wow
it used to take hundreds of people to
run these dams but today they're
controlled by two easy-going swedes
working in this Command Center from here
we control the complete river system 15
power stations and we have two guys here
who controls the complete River that's
what seems incredible to me is the two
people would handle uh half a country's
power yeah yeah you could essentially
turn on a turbine and shut off a turbine
and so today that's all done through
software yeah on the rest of our journey
today we'll get to go and see some of
these options you're going to see the
biggest one we have in Sweden and that
would be kind of equivalent to uh okay
yeah
van fall has turbines of all sizes
some of them like this big Beauty named
Esther now you see the size of it yeah
it's huge produces much power as a
nuclear reactor what
down we go this is what you've been
waiting
this feels like the seconds before a
shuttle loans it does feel like that
I've been to a couple yeah
how long does it take to get up to full
speed
here comes the water
standing next to one of these turbines
when it fires up is one of life's great
organ rattling pleasures
it's believable how fast it goes
the closer you get the more manly you
feel for some totally insane reason 250
cubic meters a second okay
that's absolutely amazing
after getting my organs rattled I
decided to head back to lulio and
decompress
damn what a day
it's been a long but awesome week in
Sweden
somehow we ended up near the arctic
circle with a campfire
it's our lucky day
I've been to Sweden a few times and this
trip confirmed my previous Impressions
about the country
these are a pleasant people who are
remarkably good at making things
everyone wants
but what's more impressive these days is
the way in which the swedes are
embracing technology the people here try
harder than anyone else to find a
balance between striving for a bright
future while living within their means
and then you know cinnamon buns
[Music]
thank you